swats continuing coverage of e3 2015
we're here with PES PES is happening or
we call a pro have already caught a pre
or Pro Evo that never seems to be a
contender get consensus about the
starting eleven who knows Adam buddy
great to have you on the stage my
friends like Konami and you're in the
the Windsor office which is right it's
kind of a new office right a cup set up
over a year and a half ago to sort of
two guys take pears into the next
generation
yeah definitely we can't take all the
credit though you know we are working
with the team in Tokyo who are leading
us and it's great to be working now I
guess we were we were created to bring
that European flavor here and give that
global understanding of the sport they
already had it they made those great ps2
games right and I think with the new
consoles coming ps4 and Xbox one
we had a new challenge and they needed
some more helps and some more hands on
deck and we're gonna enjoy Joshu here
ready to to play for us you guys I'm
probably gonna talk to out of here you
guys would you guys do you guys do your
thing alright so from the top level I
guess PES last year was a pretty solid
addition yeah you guys have been playing
catch-up with FIFA therefore it seems
like four or five years yeah that was a
while they're obviously back into the
ps2 good days we were dominating and a
football market so what's it like now
obviously the last game was Fox engine
it was like a whole new um architecture
and very well received in terms of
review is think we gave it an age got a
couple of nines as well whatwhat's this
year for you guys well this year is to
start the game start the year with a lot
more confidence
last year I was entering interviews with
people not quite sure if I was doing the
marketing spiel or not because I mean
you were very kind before actually was
probably longer maybe eight years where
pairs had lost a lot of fans and lost
you know lost a lot of respects and I
guess we took away 2008 probably was
when absolutely yeah I just realize how
old I am sorry about that but yeah but
we had to change the perception right so
last year it was a case of taking the
chance to convince people again and they
were more willing because you got the
new consumers that the new people buying
the new consoles I should say and
and they gave pears a chance so we
brought in the Fox engine as you
mentioned make the game look fantastic
we're still working with third party
engines like Harvick for the physics and
things like that and what we had last
year was a really solid football game
this year much more confident we won a
ton of awards last year we were the game
that people thought was the best the
better football game but I still want
more and more people to try PES on
actually to give it a chance and this
year is all about bringing them in nice
and easy you know letting them feel the
gameplay which is the focus is far more
responsive now we don't allow a lot of
work on the response times both
offensively and defensively we've
brought in a new collision system so it
looks real one thing that you see right
now is a brand new camera angle as well
yes it looks like it actually it's like
a broadcast cam and what they say these
guys are professional and razor a bit
better of pain thanks Andre he just
wanted to get one goal on the live
stream thank you before we show it off I
get it I want that you notice there is
the camera angle sort of the way that it
shows when the ball is is near you it'll
pan low when it's on the further end
it'll pan up and zoom in it's really
intelligent we're really happy the one
thing that you didn't see where these
guys playing is a really really strong
day I would call and get intelligent
player AI and this is just naturally
when you play football games for your
few prepares but you're used to
activating manually a a through ball or
a player run or a one two yeah now the
players will be doing that for you it
will be reacting to what you're doing
and and that's really important for us
to do is to make sure that that's kind
of one of those things where a new user
will really appreciate it
and so the big sort of I guess elephant
in the raw here we go and it's being
kind he's trying to get a little bit of
play in here yeah I guess the sort of
the big issue you guys will always have
with FIFA is that EA up the the money to
just throw around a bunch of cash and
get some licensing deals so what do you
guys have this because you always tend
to have a bunch of stuff like the
Chinese League on lockdown forever like
good relationship where you wafer
added a bunch of leagues that weren't
ever represented in FIFA before what can
we see in PES so it's difficult for me
to say too much on that we're going to
announce the licenses a little bit later
I'm getting around Gamescom it I guess
legally you actually can't talk about
well still yeah but just before we came
out to e3 we announced their renewal of
the UEFA excellent license so before we
were there licensed products now with an
official video game and it gives us a
three year extension for the Champions
League Europa League okay so that that's
cool we got a lot more coming I would
say to the fans in a kind of way where I
would say don't worry there is no bad
news coming only good news come okay so
yeah we'll probably see everything that
was before maybe some of the other
extras that said that something like
yeah I said I'm not putting words in
your mouth don't worry and yeah so like
I guess the thing about PES is whenever
I remember enjoying perhaps what I used
to do a lot was I play fifa 4 when I was
playing against AI and I'd always play
PES when I had my mates over I felt a
lot better in fact one of my favorite
football games over the past couple of
years was the Wii version that came out
about three or four years or five years
ago which is fantastic very underrated
and for you guys what's the focus
because for me PES was always a game
about playing with mates yeah so for you
guys do you like spend a lot of time
developing the career modes do you spend
more time on the online stuff yeah
what's your main focus really
interesting because one of the things
and I guess the way that pairs was made
in the past was we used to focus
singular we used to have really so last
year really good game play in really
poor modes yeah one of the things that
we really focused on this year was to
try and crave what what we're hoping to
be a triple-a product it's not just a
great scoring game where you have so
many options so many ways of playing
right so for us it's actually everything
I mean we do want to make you have fun
with your friends for sure the AI is
really important in terms of 1v1 but
also one V CPU but we redid the modes as
well so Master League is our 20th
anniversary of people keep seeing the
2000 really yeah so obviously now I feel
super star soccer back in the day yes
one you know when
eleven games so with that Master League
was one of those modes that people
really fell in love with and we've
really taken our eye off a we brought in
my club and through that so this year
we've redone Master League where you
really live the life of a manager you
see cutscenes or when you sign plays you
get press conferences and when you as a
manager move clubs we actually have this
live feed into the main menu where it
captures what what happened in the
previous match so say if you missed a
chance or score an important goal the
game will actually capture the image
from that and put it into your main menu
so you can record it and see it and
there'll be a press report about it so
that the easy sort of answer is
everything's important you playing with
your friends and you playing the modes
and stuff but also you know at the same
time it is the gameplay no matter what
you mentioned feed listen we can't
control some things we have control the
licenses they always block us out we
have got a role I'll be score to go
against my Brazil getting some revenge
fully enough Andre is Brazilians I think
that's why he's like but memories coming
over it's just like my favorite demo
ever because we have we've had other
sports games come up and they're so
rigid about like this is now we're
showing this play now we're showing this
now we're showing this you just had a
make a guy come on he knows how to play
and Joshy I think is the marketing guy
who never does really play that much
who's just like hanging out and he's
like I play it's like when you invite
one of your mates over I guess it
probably shows that the mentality of you
guys where it's just I'm really happy
all I think yeah yeah definitely no no I
mean for me personally as the product
guy working on the game yeah yeah of
course laughing I can see the aftermath
of this I think that's the you know the
thing about like the Pro Evolution
Series was for years we just it felt
like it felt like a mate if elekid came
around every couple of years and
everyone was looking for it - I love
this the San Siro is never seen football
right after you love it yeah yeah so I
think like
I guess your main problem is it's
clearly enough the problem that people
have been like virtual reality if you
want to selfie or to somebody you need
to stick a headset on them and they
don't really get it on telly I remember
thinking when I was talking to my
brother about how last year's PES are
really liked yeah and but people are
just stuck in the other eco system and
they don't come over so how do you get
this game in front of people you're
gonna do demos are you gonna like do
more outreach with with youtubers or
like how are you gonna actually get we
started to do that listen I think it's
really easy to say but before last year
nobody wanted to do that yes really and
this year we've got the respect makam
people want to
we are working with Playstation really
closely we're hoping to get a game in
front of people a lot more will announce
a demo as well but I think for us is
it's really key that people give us a
chance you know as long as it's free to
go and play it for them and for them for
them to experience it hopefully they
will go okay I'm gonna give this a go it
looks cool and hopefully you guys when
you do play it as well as weapon last
year we got a lot of credit for it as
well that's gonna make people it's not
about switching I'm not trying to get
people to switch actually I'm not that
guy who they don't come to PES I just
want to try it and you know whether you
buy both or whether you better buy just
PES I honestly feel you will really
enjoy the game and really see the
strengths you know I think the problem
is for too many years PES had been
saying the kingís back every year yeah
when you don't people stop actually
believing and trusting and and we're
hoping now that you guys think you
rather than us they they will try it as
well I mean you can see the gameplay
here and just the movement of Neymar is
super fluid you know people want a foul
in like in real life and everything oh
here we go
everything is moving as well there's no
stop and start now I heard you a cheap
goal there you deserve that no G golden
hairs yeah we can see how fluid it is
the guys moving away from challenges and
in in the past in PES there used to be a
lot of locking animations and things
like that with the new collision system
it's all freeform and you see that in
the aerial battles as well these guys
aren't showing
really well right now but when the balls
in the air you can sort of battle for
the ball
it's not about just winning it or not
now you can make a difference
you're like a small guy or a big guy you
call there you go on time on there
perfectly that's perfect but you see a
lot of bowels like that does the havoc
stuff come into play it in those
situations yeah absolutely yeah when we
sort of built the new system we had to
use that tech because Fox engine is what
we're using for the visual side yes
every I mean you've seen Fox engine
obviously Fox engine is is an engine
which has been made for a quite special
open-world game yes and we have to adapt
it to make it work in this game right so
what we've worked on a lot every here
it's bringing it with an amazing one is
bringing in these things and you can see
this oh but the way that you fell has
been calculated that's the new collision
system that we got in the game but with
Fox engine every year we're gonna make
advancements because we're always
playing catch-up yes those guys are
always doing yearly advancements so
we're always trying to adapt it's all
pairs we'll keep getting bad I'm bad um
don't be surprised at Gamescom as well
if the game looks even better he's
playing with him isn't it it's gonna be
I liked it when I got 50 I think we have
to finish this get we have to finish
this game we can't let this go without
knowing who won if if the the world
champions on the x world champions yeah
actually in real life this game was
about was the 7s if with the Germans
can't say much they got beaten by
America last week oh yeah that's right
yeah for the Women's World Cup was on at
the moment as well and obviously they're
the FIFA guys were able to get ladies
football in as a first time do you think
that's ever something you guys will have
to band with actually are though or like
focus to do as well or did they have
that lock down on licensing or anything
I don't know how that works I'm not sure
I don't think they have I think if the
fans wanted is something that we've
consider I mean I presume is something
that their fans wanted so you know good
luck to them and you know let's see how
it goes
it'll be interesting to see how many
people play the mold and yeah off like
that because I think it's I think it's
cool there's nothing bad about it it's
great so I guess it's just a case of if
our fans want to see that we'll consider
do you very different kind of space as
well though they're probably trying to
think of new things to do new avenues to
go Pez it's trying to rebuild that's
there
they can't take last year and just be
cocky we have to keep making sure that
we are delivering a great game and you
still need to advance and advance
because when those games on ps2 came out
they were like by far beyond the best
games I'm going to create a kind of gap
kind of had the same problem people have
now which is that they don't really know
what to sort of do now yeah but how
frustrated we want to listen to the fans
as well I think we've still got a lot of
stuff at the fans want us to do to be
honest when they when they play this
game I'm really happy I'm really
confident that they're gonna like it as
well
and see how we just skipped away from
it's really intelligent if this is real
life Boateng would have taken him down
no way he was gonna let him walk buzz
all right here we go it's the 89 minutes
let's see if Brazil can can get the
Germans back for that humiliation in the
world one more in the blanket o3 Nana
days my god when is there past 26 2016
err where can people play it so it's
here in the US Central and South America
September 15th Oh which is which is two
months before lust last year it is is
that also a week after Metal Gear
Solid's I think Mike's after who is
after ya the two [ __ ] engine games with
a to it yeah exactly yeah with the first
football game out of the market this
year cool nice work good call a nice
rock gentlemen thank you a great game it
was nice to see a natural video game
demo on a sports day appreciate I don't
place your fear talking so much thanks
very much gentlemen
hey Meg next World Cup Brazil yeah
thanks very much for talking guys than
that best ideas this year thank you all
right we'll be back on the GameSpot
stage with a bunch more games - stay
tuned